el número mágico en el senado es de 50
votos mayoría siempre y 50 sobre 100 el
partido que logre superar más de 50
votos tendrá la mayoría en la cámara
alta sin embargo en estas elecciones
solo 35 sillas están en juego los
demócratas entonces necesitarían 14
sillas asegurar 14 sillas teniendo en
cuenta que ya tienen escaños asegurados
porque solo 35 están en juego los
pronósticos de la página 538 una página
de pronósticos muy conocida en Estados
Unidos es muy muy apretado para la
carrera al senado y dice que la carrera
al final la mayoría en la cámara alta se
va a terminar definiendo en Estados como
Nevada Pensilvania y Michigan esos tres
estados van a ser muy importantes de
Cara a esta mayoría que quieren asegurar
los demócratas en el senado en cuanto a
la cámara de representantes Pues los
pronósticos y las encuestas han indicado
que el partido republicano el que va a
retomar el control en la cámara baja
muchas encuestas dan favorable al
partido republicano por puntos por
puntos bastante amplios en las encuestas
y el número clave a tener en cuenta en
esta elección a la cámara de
representantes es de 218 escaños es
decir el partido que logre superar esta
cifra pues asegurará la mayoría el día
de mañana Cristóbal ahora Cómo va la
votación anticipada Cuáles son los
estados en donde más se ha votado
hasta el momento son más de 43 millones
de estadounidenses que han votado de
forma anticipada a los estados que más
han votado son California Texas y la
Florida en estos estados más de 5
millones de estadounidenses han votado
ya en concreto por correo más de 20
millones de personas a
votado en concretamente 23 millones de
personas han votado por correo hasta
ahora en persona de forma anticipada son
20 millones de personas los que han
votado los republicanos como era de
esperarse pues han acudido más a las
urnas para votar y los demócratas pues
han votado de forma anticipada de por
correo Es decir por correo es como los
demócratas están votando más a
diferencia de los republicanos que lo
están haciendo en persona